this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video
you will gain an understanding of aging
clocks
what they are and why they are being
investigated the different types of
clocks being studied and which are
commercially available
as well as addressing some challenges
the clocks currently face
and whether any of the clocks are hands
down the best
get it so for now this will be a very
generic overview
i may do more specialized videos at a
later date but at least you will have
this as a go-to reference point
so before we look at some asian clocks
there are two key terms that you need to
understand
the first one is super easy and that's
chronological age
or ca as i may refer to from now on and
this is your age since birth
the second one is a bit more challenging
to interpret and that is biological age
unlike chronological age biological age
is
a so-called latent variable that is it
can only be inferred
as we'll see below but the idea is that
it provides a better prediction of your
health status
than chronological age so biological age
can be thought of as a composite
measurement
that correlates with various health
outcomes but for these reasons could
have more relevance for disease
prediction
diagnostics and treatment outcomes than
just knowing how old someone is
and so naturally chronological age and
biological age will correlate
and so therefore chronological age can
be used to evaluate
how good these different aging clocks
are so
what exactly is an aging clock then well
a simple explanation is some sort of
panel of different markers which we'll
look at later
that can be used to predict
chronological age when modelled
and so you might think then well what's
the point of understanding biological
age
while effectively here using aging
clocks you're predicting chronological
age from biological aging biomarkers
so to give an example one hopeful use of
these different aging clocks
is to be able to test the efficacy of
different anti-aging interventions
and so you can then test the
intervention and measure some biomarkers
to predict
the age that the clock gives you and
then compare that to the actual
chronological age
and so the inferred chronological age
from these asian clocks
is effectively the biological age now i
still don't feel like i fully conveyed
the idea correctly yet
so let's have a look at some features of
aging clocks that are desirable
and the first one being the idea that
it's modifiable
it's something that can be interfeined
and altered
so my chronological age will always
increase each year that i'm on planet
earth
like there's nothing i can really do
about it but i could modify
my biological age or my inferred
chronological age
from these different aging clocks
depending on my lifestyle or different
interventions that are taken so someone
might be 50 years old
but have an inferred chronological age
of these clocks which you can think of
as biological age as much older say
55 or younger such as like 45
but the funny thing with this feature is
the fact it kind of has a cat 22 issue
going on
because you want an agent clock that
changes with interventions to
evaluate how these interventions are
working but at the same time if you want
to validate the clock itself
you need to have validated anti-aging
interventions that you know are going to
work
to validate the biomarkers but anyway
we'll take a look at some of the
challenges at the end of the video
but some other features of clocks that
are going to be desirable
are going to be high prediction high
accuracy
is the clock actually giving us the
right information
the third feature is that you want it to
be highly precise and
reproducible so if you did the sample
twice would you get the same answer
because biology can be noisy and the
sensitivity of the marker being measured
could maybe over-interpret or miss
values and so there could be technical
variability as well as biological
variability
another important feature is cost as
this would definitely
affect how scalable the different clocks
are as well as how affordable
they are for people and then lastly a
very important feature is that it's
non-invasive
and can be easily measured so things
like saliva samples
cheek swabs hair samples and i guess
there's some extent blood samples
and so again these are just desirable
features it may be more informative to
have tissue samples but i don't think
there's going to be much demand in
an aging clock that requires more uh
invasive tissue samples
so agent clocks have the potential to
help evaluate different
anti-aging interventions but they could
also be useful to get a biological age
of someone
so an uninferred chronological age which
could therefore be used to predict the
risk of different diseases
sort of an early prediction and the
clocks themselves may also elucidate on
the actual
underpinning aging mechanism which could
highlight
further areas of interest and future
study and it could be that different
agent clocks
reflect different components of the
aging process
and that understanding them in total
could help us to build a better paradigm
of aging so thus now nicely brings us on
to
the different types of clocks that have
been published
so a common feature across these
different clocks is that they use
different metrics so different
biomarkers
and mathematical models typically linear
regression models are used
but within the last few years more
frequently artificial intelligence has
been used
to gather this information and predict a
value for
biological age and so i don't want to go
into too much
mathematical detail here but a linear
regression is just trying to
identify a relationship between
variables
so here the biomarkers that are being
measured
and biological age so before i go
through the clocks i do want to
apologize to any authors
who may be watching whose work i don't
mention or mention only in passing
because this area is pretty expensive
and i really just wanted to provide the
beginner's guides in this first video
so one category of human agent clocks
that you've possibly heard about
are epigenetic aging clocks otherwise
known as
dna methylation clocks since they're
based on dna methylation marks
and in particular they're based on
methylation of cytosine residues found
in cpg
sites of dna now you don't really need
to understand
what cpg sites are or methylation is to
understand
what these clocks do but effectively
they look for the presence or absence of
methyl groups at different sites in the
genome and they can do this from dna
samples
and many different epigenetic clocks
have been made
some of which are highlighted in this
timeline you can see here
albeit it's now a little bit outdated
but all of the clocks quantitatively
combine
different dna methylation levels at lots
of different sites
into a composite methylation-based age
predictor
and these have shown very high
correlations with chronological age
and in addition to being able to predict
chronological age
they've also been shown to have other
values such as being able to predict
all-cause mortality as well as mobility
and mortality risk
when other clinical aging measures are
also taken into account
so these epigenetic agent clocks have
the ability to measure biological age
and can also correlate with various
health outcomes
moreover epigenetic clocks have also
been used as evidence to show
of age this has been seen at least twice
already
firstly in the triumph study that showed
that the dna methylation age
was reversed when patients were given a
combination of human growth hormone
dhea are metformin and the other case
in which the name afflation was used was
when evaluating
the cellular reprogramming of retinal
cells treated with the yamanaka factors
described in this nature publication
from the sinclair lab last year
and so in addition to dna methylation
clocks have also now been made
using micro rnas so small rnas found
within a cell
are looking at different expression
patterns as well as using the human
microbiome
moreover clocks have been made that have
used the expression of different genes
in different tissues and so this is
known as transcriptomic data
but another area where there's now been
a lot of recent advancements have been
in protein detection
so looking at the abundance of different
proteins and developing so-called
proteomic aging clocks
for example a 2019 study developed a
proteamic agent clock
that demonstrated that individuals that
had a lower predicted age
than their chronological age performance
better at cognitive and physical tests
and similarly looking cellular proteins
but slightly different at the same time
a very recent publication has described
so-called i-age
standing for inflammatory age which is
an immune profiling agent clock
so this time the proteins that they're
identifying are proteins that are
believed to be involved in
the immune response and other
inflammatory factors
now not only does it have a pretty good
name for a clock i age
but they also showed in their study that
it could be used to predict
multi morbidity and felty and they get
one from that to try and
decipher which components that they are
profiling
could be a major contributor to this
correlation
and they identified the protein cxcl9
suggesting that this protein is an
important factor in age-related chronic
inflammation
and so it goes back to the idea of if we
can understand what these different
clocks are measuring it may help us to
further understand
the aging process itself and what
factors might be critical to it
because that could also then give rise
to different target sites
but it isn't necessarily guaranteed that
the clocks themselves
are causal molecular processes that
underpin aging
and in fact it's currently thought that
these different aging clocks
may be reflecting different aspects of
aging
and so this kind of leads on to the next
section which is one of the major
challenges for the field at the moment
and that definitely includes being able
to use these
predictive clocks that have been
developed and kind of deciphering them
and working backwards to really see what
is it they're actually identifying what
is it they're picking up how does this
relate to aging
well that isn't the only challenge that
the agent clocks face at the moment
the second one is trying to identify the
best sample source
and going back to what i was saying
earlier about the noise in the data
being both technical and biological as
for example doing
the tests at different times of the day
could give different
readings albeit that information in
itself could be quite interesting to
understand
and so that goes in line with how many
measurements would be needed for
a precise measurement would you have to
take three and
get an average or would one suffice
also are the clock sex specific while
some have been demonstrated to be
predictive for both males and females i
probably would be surprised if the
efficacy of some of the clocks
were not improved if sex-dependent
differences
were taken into account and another
interesting point to raise
is the fact that i've mentioned how
these different clocks may be reflecting
different
components of aging and so therefore
certain
tests may be more appropriate for
different interventions
or maybe not appropriate in that case as
well
and so i guess to try and explain what i
mean if we go back to the ih clock i
mentioned with cx09 being a major
contributor
if i had somehow completely depleted it
or knocked out of my cells and ended
this test
my age prediction would be very low
after this
intervention yet it may not actually be
a good thing to do if that makes any
sense
basically i think what i'm trying to say
is you want to use a clock that's not
biased towards a certain intervention
but doing that in an unbiased way i also
think would be quite challenging
anyway i also said in this video we
would talk about what clocks are
currently available
and well i actually came across a very
good resource that i'm just gonna
refer you to because it's pretty much
listed every clock that's currently
available and gives some generic
information to it so
you'll find a link to that in the
description so yeah i got lucky on that
one
so uh with that hopefully this has been
a very good
intro video to agent clocks i know i
haven't covered
all of the different types of clocks
available but i do hope to do some
follow-up videos
if that is something of interest so with
that
i'd like to thank the sponsor for this
week's video longevity technology for
which i'm very grateful
longevity technology delivers high
quality daily news and insights
on research investments and technologies
that extend health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening